pay for school I'm going to help pick
the school my kids go to I'm not going
to send them to these woke schools
because they've professionalize
indoctrinating your children and they're
very good at it and I can lose my own
kids so I try to send them now I have so
many kids I can get it wrong and then
get it right later but I think it's
important to note that all these
professors are very liberal you don't
have conservative professors on campus
and judge you're right they're concerned
about being you know punished whether
it's their grades there they could be
you know canceled online they could be
kicked out of college for what they say
and I think it's great when you have a
you know a well-informed young
conservative debating a teacher that can
Inspire other kids and go hey really
good point I'm with this guy not the
teacher that's a great thing but I mean
I think this if you look at a threat to
democracy it's these universities that
are a threat to democracy 62 percent of
college students think it's acceptable
to shut down a speaker by yelling at
them 20 percent think that they can use
violence to shut down speech this is
crazy town for all of us who used to go
to school back you know 10 20 30 years
ago